on
[Musique]
parle de football et surtout du
transfert des stars du ballon rond il ya
souvent débats et polémiques au sujet
des montants faramineux de cet échange
de cet événement aux répercussions quasi
planétaire c'est bien sûr l'arrivée de
lionel messi au psg quand il se pourrait
bien que nous soyons tous gagnants avec
l'annoncé de l'arrivée de lionel messi
au psg nombreux sont ceux qui se sont
indignés des 120 millions d'euros nets
que le joueur l'a touché sur deux ans
l'arrivée de lionel messi au psg par
rapporter beaucoup d'argent que cet
argent ne va pas seulement profiter à
l'argentin de 34 ans quand en effet
entre les prestations sociales que le
psg va verser à l'état à hauteur de 39
millions d'euros et les 10 millions
d'euros que le joueur devra au trésor
public ce ne sont pas moins de 49
millions d'euros par an qui seront
collectés dans les caisses du pays soit
98 millions pour ses 2 ans minimum au
psg énorme ce calcul ne prend pas en
compte le chiffre a porté par les ventes
de produits dérivés qui devrait être
colossal sur lequel la tva est prélevée
là encore pour la collectivité une
opération commerciale qui profitera donc
à chaque français y compris les
supporters de l'om
finalement ça n'est pas la fin à un
débat sur t2 tropez finalement
s'approche mais ça mais la fin à un
débat tout simplement est aujourd'hui en
france qu'on a un sérieux problème sur
les gens qui gagnent de l'argent c'est
pour ça que je ne vienne plus ou moins
voilà
tout le bon que ça peut apporter aussi
pour notre pays pour l'état fin pour
plein de choses et l'argent qui le fait
gagner quitte le sens des départs et
des bouches derrière en fait c'est
incroyable c'est que le salon
wii mario sur la ligue 1 telecinco
qu'est la chaîne espagnole a diffusé le
premier match de messi au psg ça fait 7
millions de tester alors c'est énorme
c'est plus une france et les fan de
messi pardon mais qui ne connaissait pas
en effet la ligue 1 ont regardés en
streaming mais les 20 minutes où il a
joué entre des millions c'était des
records ils vont prendre des abonnements
pour pouvoir regarder justement ces
matches et surtout footballistiquement
c'est le club qui va gagner mais
financièrement c'est la france avec
toutes les retombées les ventes de
t-shirts de maillots ont explosé en
vingt minutes 800 dont le jackpot pour 6
millions d'euros
mais il permettait à l'espagne quand
même de gagner plus de 100 millions
d'euros par rapport à ces à son effigie
a par exemple gagné
miscibles
d'euros de bénéfices même ses missiles
jusqu'au bout de son contrat en 2024 le
total dû à l'état serait de 147 millions
d'euros c'est maintenant les citoyens
contribuables
aucun contribuable ne mettra un euro
dans cette histoire dont il faut le
savoir parce que le peuple à chaque fois
devant
l'impôt oui non si vous dites est vrai
mais pas ménagé ses rangs non non mais
cissé sait pas quoi regarder attendez je
lui fermer notre
tribu aux salaires des gros joueurs
aucun contribuable le contribuer aux
salaires des grands joueurs et qu'ils
aient le plus grand gagnant là dedans
france et notre cyril hanouna qui va
kiffer quand il va les voir ces matches
à la france on veut dire ainsi google